confrérie secrète opère dans l'ombre à
rivarennes les aujourd'hui à lord a
menacé d'extinction pour arriver ses
forces vives le grand matelas pas là
vous le décor de la mission est planté
perdu en plein coeur d'un domaine
viticole de plus de 15 hectares nos
détectives du jour ont 75 minutes montre
en main pour retrouver le mystérieux
trésor de la confrérie du cèpe partie
une immersion unique dans les coulisses
du métier de vigneron va revenir le long
des poteaux en continuant deschamps et
qui vont visiter le domaine ils vont
visiter les vignes et toute la nature
qui est autour puis aussi le stockage du
vin dans les caves pour après pouvoir
visiter et connaître la vraie nature du
domaine pagé et de ce qu'est un vigneron
l'occasion pour nos viticulteurs en
herbe de faire plus ample connaissance
avec les différents cépages qui les
entoure en rouge elles n'ont porte le
vignoble aoc ample fruits frais car chez
les pages et la vigne c'est une histoire
de famille depuis la fin du 19e siècle
cinq générations se sont succédé sur ses
terres entre traditions d'antan et
innovation biologique un riche
patrimoine familial qu'ont voulu
partager pascaline et son mari à travers
cette escape game ça nous permet de
recevoir une clientèle qui n'oseraient
pas forcément venir en dégustation
juste pour goûter les vins ça nous
permet aussi de
communiquer autrement sur sur la vigne
sur ce qui se passe toute l'année plus
que c'est pas s'est pas limitée qu'on
vendange et
codes secrets calcul scientifique encre
invisible c'est lequel est idyllique
l'énigme laisse parfois nos enquêteurs
perplexes faut aller en dessous de la
crosse de rugy cela mais bon si
compliqué parce que on sait pas vraiment
un mais après quelques minutes de
recherches dans la région
les nouveaux chevaliers de la confrérie
du cèpe parties peuvent enfin prêté
serment une
intronisation bachique très appréciée de
nos jeunes aventuriers change surtout de
la plupart des disques ils viennent
parce que c'est surtout dans les salles
mais là on était en extérieur je me suis
beaucoup amusé c'est la première fois
que je fais un escalier une comme ça et
ça m'a beaucoup plu c'est super bien on
se balade et beaucoup comme sacha
dégourdi un peu et surtout à la fin à la
salle et je m'y attendais pas du tout
amoureux des jeux d'évasion les parents
sont eux aussi comme qui on aime bien
faire partager notre passion aux enfants
donc ils aiment bien ça aussi et puis ça
change d'être à l'extérieur et puis ben
nous on aime bien le vin donc on était
content de faire un mix cabine dans les
mini change un petit peu de l'ordinaire
par rapport aux visites classiques
château vous pouvez avoir dans cette
merveilleuse région donc voilà ça fait
des très bons souvenirs située à 40
minutes de tours l'escape game du
domaine pages et est accessible sur
réservation jusqu'au vacances de la
toussaint